und häufiger hier gesprochen hat als
ergebnis einer der gründe warum er ist
dass er schon sehr lange außenminister
ist es ist aber doch ungewöhnlich und
dafür bin ich auch sehr dankbar dass sie
fast jedes mal soweit ich mich erinnern
kann wir gewesen sind sie haben sich
immer zeit genommen hierher zu kommen
und vor diesem publikum zu sprechen und
mit uns manchmal auch kontroverse fragen
zu diskutieren
ich weiß dass manchmal dieses publikum
auch dass ihnen das leben nicht leicht
gemacht hat ich kenne aber nicht viele
die so sehr profi sind wie sie was die
diplomatie betrifft also respekt und wir
freuen uns sehr dass ich wieder hier
sind sie sprechen wir für die russische
föderation und ich möchte ihn jetzt ohne
weitere spalten das mikrofon anbieten
ich hoffe wir haben nachher noch zeit
für fragen
[Applaus]
diese generation möchte ich die
freundlichen worte es gibt einen
weiteren grund weshalb ich hier am
häufigsten sprecher du bist auch solange
auf seinem posten
aber heute ist es nun mal so dass die
lage auf dem europäischen kontinent und
insgesamt im euro atlantischen raum sehr
angespannte ist es treten neue brüche
auf und das tun sich walter alte immer
wieder weiter auf und ich glaube unter
diesen umständen ist es durchaus an der
zeit über die idee ist gewalt das
gesamte europäischen hauses zu sprechen
die potenziale aller europäischen
staaten müssen gebündelt werden und
diese notwendigkeit wurde von allen
großen politiker der gegenwart erkannt
von charter gold der das konzert des
großen europas von atlantik bis zum ural
vorgebracht hat das sollte ein
friedliches europa ohne trennlinien
werden ohne block konfrontation die nach
seiner meinung europa künstlich und
fruchtlos machen würden dass eine breit
aufgestellte partnerschaft mit russland
zum wohle der stabilität und sicherheit
in europa wichtig ist sagte
bundeskanzler kohl und präsident veteran
nach dem ende des kalten krieges halten
all diese edlen vorsätze alle chancen
erfolgreich realisiert zu werden doch
bedauerlicherweise sind sie bloß gute
vorsätze geblieben
man hat sich für eine nato zentrierte
entschieden für die logik der führende
und der folgende die illegitimen
bombardierungen jugoslawiens seine
aufteilung und die unabhängige
einseitiger die einseitige anerkennung
der unabhängigkeit des kosovo die zum
ersten mal nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
die staatsgrenzen auf dem kontinent
verschoben haben die unterstützung für
den militärputsch in kiew die zügellose
erweiterung der nato und die aufstellung
der amerikanischen raketenabwehr in
europa die weigerung der europäischen
union die damals durch moskau und
abgestimmt und brüssel abgestimmte
entscheidung zu treffen
den visumszwang aufzuheben die
diskriminierung der russischen
abgeordneten in der parlamentarischen
versammlung des europarates das sind
alles glieder einer kette dabei möchte
ich hinzufügen dass es zwischen russland
und der europäischen union als
offizielle fahrplan gegeben hat die sich
auf vier gemeinsame räume bezogen haben
von wirtschaft und justiz bis hin zur
wissenschaft und bildung
diese fahrpläne sind mittlerweile dem
vergessen anheim gefallen und niemand
erinnert sich mehr daran ganz zu
schweigen von einer aktiven arbeit daran
und diese fahrpläne wurden auf höchster
ebene beschlossen das gleiche gelte auch
für die verpflichtung die eigene
sicherheit nicht auf kosten der
sicherheit von anderen zu gewährleisten
diese verpflichtung wurde auf höchster
ebene in den dokumenten der osze und des
russland nato rates beschlossen und
dieser verpflichtung ist nicht bloß
vergessen worden
dieser verpflichtung wird schlaganfalls
was haben wir dann im endeffekt ein
gemeinsames europa ist somit nicht
gebaut worden ein großes potenzial der
russisch europäische zusammenarbeit die
vorteile aus dieser zusammenarbeit
werden nicht genutzt die für uns alle
drängenden probleme von der endgültigen
bekämpfung des terrorismus bis hin zur
gewährleistung einer nachhaltigen
wirtschaftswachstums wir hatten
da kommen keine angemessenen antworten
während europäer sich in diese sinnlose
rivalität mit russland haben
hineinziehen lassen und während sie
milliardenschwerer verluste von denen
aus übersee aufgezwungen sanktionen
einstecken ist die welt weiter dabei
sich rapide zu verändern praktisch
gesehen verfügt die europäische union
über keine monopolstellung mehr bei der
gestaltung der gesamt regionalen
integrations tagesordnung
das kräfteverhältnis auf einem
gemeinsamen europäischen arabischen raum
verlagert sich vor allem durch die
entstehung neuer zentren im asiatisch
pazifischen raum ein fester bestandteil
der politischen landschaft ist die
organische wirtschaftsunion geworden
ein zeichen dafür wo durch konkrete
ergebnisse
dabei erreicht wurden als auch durch die
bestrebungen von dutzenden staaten und
bündnissen mit arabischem
wirtschaftsunion präferenzen abkommen
abzuschließen auch die chinesische
volksrepublik leistet einen beitrag dazu
und sie engagiert sich für das concept
one by one roth es gibt entsprechende
offene integrationsprojekte die auch auf
der s t plattform weiter vorangetrieben
werden ich bin davon überzeugt die
voranbringen verschiedene
integrationsprojekte darf nicht mit
einer konfrontation oder rivalität
einhergehen wir sehen wie sie gute
möglichkeiten eröffnen um potenziale
zusammen zu bilden um verschiedene
multilateraler vorsätze zu realisieren
neue wachstumsquellen auszumachen die
bemühungen um einen gemeinsamen
wirtschaftsraum werden mittlerweile
unternommen durch die zusammenarbeit
zwischen der zwischen der moralischen
wirtschaftsunion und one by one droht
diese programme ergänzen sich harmonisch
auch die gespräche zwischen der
eurasischen wirtschaftsunion und der
asian erstarken weiter auch mit der
shanghaier kooperationsorganisation all
diese prozesse folgen der initiative von
präsident putin die er vor einigen
jahren vorgebracht hat um eine große
russische partnerschaft auf die beine zu
stellen das ist ein großes
integrationsprojekt das auf den werten
des völkerrechts der offenheit und
transparenz aufbaut
nicht verbal sondern auch tatkräftig
läuft die arbeit an die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung auf unserem gemeinsamen
immensen reichen festland unteilbar zu
machen ich glaube dass die europäischen
partner davon nur profitieren werden
werden sie sich in dieser arbeit
einbringen werden
die ausgestaltung eines gemeinsamen
raumes von lissabon bis wladiwostok
dicht verbal sondern tatkräftig wird die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit aller akteure
verbessern insbesondere mit blick auf
die anderen starken den egoismus auf
internationalen märkten mit blick auf
die versuche überall und allen eigene
spielregeln unter umgehung der vereinten
nationen wto-regeln aufzubringen schon
längst überfällig ist die technische
frage einen nachhaltigen dialog zwischen
terroristischen kommission und der
europäischen kommission in die wege zu
leiten
dazu sind wir bereit diese erstarken der
wirtschaftliche interdependenz könnte
eine gute grundlage für eine gleiche
unteilbare sicherheit würden ich möchte
sie daran erinnern wir müssen noch die
zusage erfüllen die wir uns bei dem osze
gipfel in astana 20.10 aufgeladen haben
im raum der osze sollte eine freie
demokratische gemeinsamer und unteilbare
sicherheitsgemeinschaft entstehen
russland und das allen zahlreichen
spekulationen zum trotz hat ein
interesse an einer starken
eigenständigen da unten offenen
europäischen union
präsident putin hat neulich darüber
gesprochen im oktober vergangenen jahres
als er darauf hingewiesen hat dass die
bestrebungen der eu nach unabhängigkeit
eigenständigkeiten souveränität im
bereich der verteidigung und sicherheit
einer natürlich ist uns sehr positiv zu
bewerten heißt was die erstattung der
multipolarität dieser welt inwiefern das
der europäischen union gestattet sein
wird bleibt dahin gestellt die
realitäten des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts legen die notwendigkeit
nahe auf den rückfall an das kolonial
denken zu verzichten auf eiserne
vorhänge zu verzichten auf gehalt zu
verzichten das gesamteuropäische haus
braucht eine generalsanierung diese
aufgaben sind sehr groß sie sind nur
gemeinsam zu lösen auf universaler
grundlage und in letzter zeit gibt es
vorschläge das als effektiver sei nicht
im sinne der universalität zu arbeiten
sondern im
sinne einer neuen multilaterale t zu
arbeiten und diese neue multi la reid
bedeutet dass klubs nach interessen
gestaltet werden aber das würde einen
großen rückschlag bedeutenden großen
schritt nach hinten bedeutend von dem
weshalb wir die vereinten nationen
überhaupt geschaffen haben das würde den
versucht bedeuten die vereinten nationen
durch einen klub der auserwählten zu
ersetzen
das hatten wir schon und das wird nichts
gutes bringen ich danke ihnen für ihre
aufmerksamkeit und sind bereit ihre
fragen zu beantworten
[Applaus]
wir haben zeit für ein paar fragen und
ich habe schon ein paar fragen gesammelt
die erste frage bei der ersten frage
geht es um rüstungskontrolle wir haben
jetzt natürlich nicht die zeit da tiefer
in die substanz einzusteigen und die
einzelheiten des vertrages aber die
frage ist folgende wir sind die
russischen erwartungen wie es ihre
politik in bezug auf eine weitere
fortführung des neuen staates
denn putin hat hier jetzt mehrmals
gesagt dass wir bereit sind eine
verhandlung über die verlängerung dieses
vertrags aufzunehmen der läuft ja erst
einmal 20 2021 ab aber das geht ja
schnell deswegen haben wir angeboten die
diskussionen jetzt zu beginnen
dann können auch einige der sorgen
vielleicht schon ausgeräumt werden
es geht um die entscheidung einige der
u boot gestützte favoriten für tom rock
und schwere bomber zu demokratisieren
also diese denuklearisierung sollte
stattfinden aber sie muss auch technisch
akzeptiert seien als zuverlässig die
müssen auch von der anderen
vertragspartei akzeptiert werden bis
jetzt hat man uns noch keine bedeutenden
konsultationen angeboten aber wir
bleiben weiter tragen wir versuchen das
weiter
ihr film an jetzt haben wir eine frage
die ich für sehr interessant halte eine
frage aus norwegen sind werden wir in
der lage seien weiterhin den arktischen
praktische kooperation zu schützen
auch wenn sich die ost west beziehungen
verschlechtern
und wer meint er genau wenn er sagt wir
ich denke mal er meint uns alle
russland und der westen russland und
norwegen russland und westliche länder
wenn es an uns liegt dann ist die
antwort natürlich ja ganz eindeutig
natürlich haben wir gesteigerte
aktivitäten seitens der nato als seitens
der nato mitgliedsstaaten das haben wir
schon mit unseren norwegischen nachbarn
besprochen und wir würden gerne besser
verstehen welches mandat die nato in
arktischen raum haben wird wenn sie
hören was einige sagen
wie der verteidigungsminister des
vereinigten königreichs sagen ich hätte
was gesagt der kriegsminister dann
bekommen sie vielleicht den eindruck
dass niemand außer der nato das recht
hat sich irgendwo aufzuhalten außer bei
sich zu hause
wir haben also schon konstruktive
vorschläge gemacht projekte für den
optischen raum andere nordische
strukturen
wir sind nicht der meinung dass wir bei
der arktischen zusammenarbeit eine
militärische dimension brauchen
ich hoffe dass das auch weiterhin der
fall sein wird bei unseren partnern gut
wir haben jetzt noch eine frage von ein
herz in crysis aktie
ich lese die frage vor anfrage zu syrien
warum versucht russland nicht in
konflikt politisch zu beenden
fragezeichen und dann noch spezifisch
zulagen wie beabsichtigt russland die
terroristen in der stadt ohne
militärische offensive auszuschalten
gut die erste frage da ist die antwort
eigentlich offensichtlich es braucht man
gar nicht fragen warum sollte man
überhaupt politische lösungen suchen
ich glaube nicht dass ich das
beantworten muss zum thema idlib sie
wissen ja wir haben mit im september mit
der türkei memorandum unterzeichnet und
demgemäß hat die türkei sich
verpflichtet eine trennung vorzunehmen
zwischen den oppositionsgruppen die mit
ankara kooperieren von gruppen wie einst
radiert
breiteren rahmen auftreten mit anderen
gruppen derzeit ist es nicht möglich und
leider sind ist die isra front noch
nicht besiegt wurden mehr als 90 prozent
des territoriums diese koalition in
idlib sind noch unter kontrolle die
präsidenten von russland der türkei und
iran haben sich in sotschi getroffen vor
zwei tagen ersten wir haben diese
situation diskutiert gemeinsam mit
anderen themen und wir haben uns
geeinigt dass die streitkräfte von
russland und der türkei mit zustimmung
der syrischen regierung versuchen werden
einen schrittweisen ansatz zu verfolgen
wir werden mehrere zonen definieren und
dort gemeinsam patroullieren in dieser
zone
wir werden sehen wie das funktioniert
präsident putin hat ja gesagt wir können
das nicht für immer tolerieren dass dort
eine brutstätte des terrorismus
fortbesteht
aber das liegt bei den streitkräften das
problem zu lösen
die metas werden das sicher nicht so
machen wie das in racker passiert ist
mit den terroristen und dort haben wir
finden wir immer noch die sterblichen
überreste von zivilisten
es liegen dort immer noch minen die
nicht geräumt werden aber wie gesagt das
ist eine militärische frage die militärs
werden einen plan erarbeiten und der
wird den internationalen grundsätzen für
menschenrechte entspreche
natürlich kann man das so und so
interpretieren
zum beispiel ist es schon passiert dass
ein personenzug bombardiert wurde und
einige waren der meinung das ist
akzeptabel das so interpretieren wir
menschenrechte nicht noch eine
anschlussfrage auch zum thema syrien und
diese frage kommt von jacques rogge von
der washington post
russland ist ja jetzt der
sicherheitsgarant russland syriens und
er schreibt noch dazu herzlichen
glückwunsch
wie werden sie also russland wie werden
sie sicherstellen dass das assad-regime
aufhört die region zu bedrohen und
gräueltaten gegen die eigene bevölkerung
begeht
naja egal welche antwort ich jetzt gebe
sie schreiben ja sowieso was sie wollen
also tun sie das einfach gut
diese kurzen antworten sorgen dafür dass
wir mehr fragen stellen können
ich kann das auch noch kürzer machen gut
noch eine frage von lüthi koffern sitzt
normalerweise irgendwo da drüben er
mitglied der grünen partei im
europäischen parlament ihre regierung
also die russische regierung hat
versucht einzugreifen
die angelegenheiten griechenlands und
nord mazedoniens indem sie
nationalistische kräfte dort gefördert
haben wie passt das zu ihrem anspruch
die europäische union zu unterstützen
da werde ich eine antwort geben
ich hätte auch die gleiche antwort geben
können
man hat uns vorgeworfen wir würden
eingreifen in diesen namensstreit für
mazedonien nord mazedonien
es wurden aber keine wirklichen fakten
vorgelegt für diese behauptung ich habe
gestern mit jens stoltenberg drauf
angesprochen und auch mit anderen und
jens selbst hat gesagt er hat er hat
gesagt fünf oder sechs westliche
politiker unter anderem auch der
amerikanische außenminister
verteidigungsminister hätten die region
besucht hätten wir tatsächlich das getan
was man uns vorwirft oder auch nur zum
hundertsten teil
dann hätte das wäre hätte man das doch
festgestellt
als der kosovo isoliert wurde und
einseitig zu einem unabhängigen staat
ausgerufen wurde und die meisten
westlichen staaten akzeptierten das
haben wir vor den folgen gewarnt
und jetzt
wenn man jetzt ein bisschen als macht
was es will
man spricht er von einer regelbasierten
weltordnung also manchmal spricht man
von einer regelbasierten weltordnung
manchmal spricht man von völkerrecht ich
verstehe das so dass man dort gar nicht
das völkerrecht beachten möchte wie man
es zum beispiel in der konvention über
chemie waffen niedergelegt hat dort
möchte man eigene regeln die man selber
erfinden kann und die verstoßen gegen
die bestimmung des chemiewaffen
übereinkommen ist resolution 12 55 da
geht es um kosovo und das ist ja gesagt
wird der gesamt keine streitkräfte
aber jetzt gilt anscheinend die regel
dass kosovo eine eigene streitkräfte
haben darf das hat aber die uno gar
nicht gebilligt in der resolution 12 44
steht ja vieles vieles was nicht befolgt
wird
selbst die bestrebungen der eu die als
vermittler tätig war
bei dem abkommen
diejenigen die von der parlamentarischen
versammlung
beschuldigt wurden
organhandel zu unterstützen auch da ist
nichts passiert und das wird auch nicht
aufhören
heute hat christina beschlossen 100
prozent der zölle auf die importe aus
serbien zu erheben das wurde von den usa
und der eu kritisiert aber ich habe
überhaupt keinen zweifel dass hier eine
koordination stattgefunden hat mit
denjenigen die sicherstellen wollen dass
belgrad kosovo schneller anerkennt und
bei diesem spiel geht es um genau das
gestern glaube ich hatte der
premierminister von winnie einer
griechischen zeitung gesagt
das kosovo gehört zu albanien
gut wir haben noch zeit für eine letzte
kurze frage und hoffentlich auch eine
kurze antwort habe ich den rumänischen
präsident johannes gefragt denn er
vertritt ja ein land das eine grenze zum
schwarzen meer hat ich habe ihn
gefragten auch instabilitäten im in der
schwarzmeerregion und die position der
eu zu diesem thema also vor diesem
hintergrund der jüngsten konflikte die
jüngsten streitigkeiten im asowschen
meer der spannungen im schwarzmeer
bereich diese spannungen scheinen ja zu
steigen sie werden sicher nicht weniger
können sie uns also kurz darstellen wie
die russische position zum thema
schwarzmeerregion und zu diesen und
witten aussieht
wenn sie dabei den vorfall meinen mit
der ukrainischen marine
das war eine gezielte provokation da
habe ich gar keine zweifel dass wurde
gezielt eingesetzt im bezug mit dem
wahlkampf in der ukraine das ist ja im
september passiert zwei ukrainische
marineboote sind durch die meerenge ohne
probleme ins als auch schmerz erfahren
weil sie die sicherheitsvorschriften
beachtet haben also jeder der ins offene
meer fahren will muss diese regeln
beachten und das haben sie gemacht die
haben die sicherheitsvorschriften
beachtet und das war kein problem
im november wollte man stattdessen einen
skandal inszenieren und so ist das
passiert
einige haben illusionen über die krim
das war aber diese geben um die es ging
war es schon vor dem referendum
russisches territorialgewässer es gibt
ja sicherheitsbedenken im schwarzen meer
und ich weiß die frage war ja was die eu
darüber denkt die eu hat viele regionale
initiativen gestartet im schwarzmeer
bereich im baltischen bereich da haben
wir auch nichts dagegen wir möchten nur
die eben bitten dass sie doch so nett
sind und die strukturen respektieren
dies in bestimmten regionen schon gibt
im schwarzen meer in der kaspischen meer
im schwarzen meer haben wir zwei
mechanismen siehe die anrainer staaten
beschlossen haben die schwarzmeer
kooperation und auch die harmonie
initiative eine türkische initiative
auch von anderen ländern
unterstützt es geht um wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit natürlich darum geht es
und diese harmonie initiative ist von
den anrainerstaaten beschlossen wurden
und ich bin der meinung wir dazu
beitragen will zur stabilität im
schwarzmeer bereich sollte diese
strukturen beachten
die eu wurde hier eingeladen und ist
auch beobachter bei der schwarzmeer
kooperation und wir werden ja sehen wie
sich das entwickelt
vielen dank
[Applaus]